what's up bros oh it's gaming
time resident evil 2 that's right
everybody they made a remake out of this
and it looks
actually pretty good usually remakes are
pretty [__]
actually i take that back i played this
yesterday and it crashed
because you okay sorry too many thoughts
at the same time felix think about what
you're gonna say
yesterday i recorded this you only get
one chance to play this demo
uh for 30 minutes so i recorded it and
it crashed
and then the game was like ooh sorry we
did the [__] working
shall we so i couldn't play it so now
here i am playing it on a playstation
what norm is playing on playstation i
know
i know this is super embarrassing like
honestly
uh but here we go here we freaking go
guys i'm actually excited to play this
to finally prove once and for all that i
am in fact a gamer
and i'm playing a horror game smash like
pewdiepie plays horror game
i think that's pretty like worthy it was
supposed to be a short break for leon s
kennedy just one last pit stop at a gas
station
on the outskirts of town when the rookie
cop found himself surrounded in a sea of
zombies
along with a newfound friend claire
redfield i love that
the japanese obsession with american
names and american characters
claire redfield have you ever met anyone
named that leon
managed to maybe i'm wrong i don't know
escape to raccoon city
only for an accident to split them apart
definitely navigating through the
pirellia sister streets pirellius leon
has made his way to the city's police
station but has he really made it to
safety
question mark hmm i wonder
probably not i remember this seeing that
scene as a kid
i've only played this game very briefly
i was too scared to play it
when i was a kid and he's speaking
japanese
oh so sexy
leon nihongo days
has she mean matched it kunichiwa leon
this is oh god his heart his hair looks
so sexy
oh my god
there's two people there
that means can you see
i'm somewhat of a japanese
oh you can just push them away that's
all you got to do just push them away
hey it's as easy as abc all right so
he's in the
the red room
which means murder backwards in case you
didn't know that
i'm somewhat of an expert on everything
all right so i guess [__] i my knowledge
of
resident evil games is very slim the
only one i've played fully is the last
one
which was very good by the way
um i hope they do the same like they did
with resident evil
as they did with the silent hill because
silent hill is just a
beautiful series that has been kind of
lost you know the silent hill remake is
known for being like the worst remake
ever or just getting it completely wrong
what is this
some kind of puzzle uh
i think they made it so like the shadow
and the fog in in
in silent hill didn't actually work like
you could see through the fog
whoever makes these decisions [__]
idiots
okay so yeah okay i combine it sorry
sorry if i
i genuinely don't know how to play this
game let that be known
and because i am a noob
at resident evil but like if you guys
want to give me tips
to help me play the game like a little
stronger that would be really cool
like we can work together and accomplish
goddamn doors
oh i know this we just need some some
tape cutters
impenetrable tape everyone
keep out ha can't tell me what to do i'm
from sweden
pulling lever now herro kunichiba
i am leon kennedy from get the boy
okay let's go in here very epic
i'm ruining mood mrna but it looks just
like me guys
rpd which stands for role playing dicks
good joke felix oh god this is actually
creepy
ooh looks like i totally messed up this
is very bad
i should check i need a fuse dude the
graphics looks good man i don't know
what then
oh god it's it's happening what's
happening
hello is anybody there
this is super scary hacha okay
it looks like we're safe bro
my aim is so off dude look at that
what are these shoes not on my watch
what what did you say i think i know how
to say that but i'm too scared
you know i'm nihongo as [__] okay
all right well this is a trap let that
be known
this a trap you gotta shoot him in the
ass just to be safe
should i shoot him in the ass for the
meme
or should i play this responsibly so
people don't get pissed off
oh sorry miss click okay so he's dead
well at least now we know you know hey
look he gave us ammo
well i know where the ammo came from
i'm ruining the game i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'll play
responsibly what kind of video were they
making here
what kind of strange porno very weird
my sensitivity is too high i'm like oh
we got the light switch
okay he's probably gonna come back alive
i think
that would make sense we'll hit a button
or something
i'll come back can i remove these all i
can do is hit a light switch
which is not epic
now turn it on you ding dong is there
really nothing else for me to do here
am i that [__] stupid i hate when you
you're playing on a timer right so it's
like i don't want to mess up
but honestly like why would they put
this room here
if there was nothing to find but i
generally can't see anything
all right all right we can squeeze
through here
i did hold game you think i'm not a
gamer that don't know how to
press hold obligatory
press button to proceed while the game
slows you down for a second moment
very epic a hydrant oh hi
trend see i should
be the voice actor of this game oh god
oh god
[Music]
a second
he's gonna get sucked out oh
ew oh jeez oh look i did this
i'm sorry i am so sorry
hey
oh my god oopsie doopsy
whoopsie i did an oopsy
is my hair still free
okay so his officer notebook says
the statue oh yeah that's the puzzle and
he couldn't find it
but he figured out the lion he figured
out the unicorn and he figured out the
sparrow
but we just need the order
okay so medallion goddess statue all
right so that must be them
hang in there buddy i'm coming to save
you very soon
oh god is my hair still pretty
yes oh jesus [__] christ
[Applause]
why won't you die woof that was close
bros
don't hurt me no more
oh god he can enter welcome
oh god i'm really bad at this i know
this is painful to watch but i'm trying
why won't you die step on you
why got like 5 000 head shots on you bro
we need that dead space stomp i'm sorry
i'm really rusty guys
i'll get better as we go i know it is
the most fun ever to watch the [__]
noob play
pewdiepie is such a noob
first aid spray amazing do i not have
space right yeah i do
nothing like some healing from the
toilet actually looks kind of clean
all right i'm not scared only cowards
are scared and i'm not one of them
in fact i would go as far as to say i
don't think ah
god damn it
all right now let's do epic aim this is
this is target like this
look at that beautiful unlike your face
your face is very ugly look at your face
they're totally destroyed by myself
can i have a moment of serious please
hello has anything changed in here no
there's no reason
here maybe later sorry guys
it's been epis
oh god i hear someone oh there it is
get away from me man
wait i need to combine that what is
combining the ammo dude
can be used to board windows riff raff
i love riffraff so does this guy
i don't know what refresh means just for
the record in case it's something racist
just for the record i don't know what it
all right we could have found the fuse
maybe that's what we could have done
before scrolling time
not oh god
oh jesus
don't bite him he's too pretty to die
well this guy is a lot better than we
are that's saving people crawling oh
you're dead
this is so good with the japanese voice
acting
it sounds so cool
foreign
ooh arigatou gozaimasu
is he foreshadowing me killing him
oh my god what a nihongo moment
wow that's so cool
all right so how do i do that ready sub
weapon
l1 and r2 hello
you don't look too good can i help you
i can't do it around him i have to be
further away
what now i can do it at all hey
it won't do it oh it won't let me stab
him
lame super lame what if i do it from
behind
nope okay you're wasting time felix you
only have 30 minutes to play this game
okay well let's see if we can solve this
impossible puzzle
oh yeah wait let me see here uh
in loving memory of those who served
with the valor of lions
the nobility of unicorns and whose
ultimate sacrifice is as
pure as the maidens of old
old maidens that's not epic
all right let's check out
uh all right so how do i open my items
then
no we're looking at the item right
there it is uh
so the crown or the goat or
the unicorn
wait there we go
hey look at that lion medallion
i wonder well i need to take it right
yeah
let's put it in right away so we don't
waste slight inventory
broski i solved the puzzle it was very
cool
oh wait it goes here
cry more okay listen
okay it went there automatically so
okay that's english for
god damn it are you not gonna help me
where do i need to go now then
need to run faster ain't got all day son
okay okay okay okay okay okay oh i know
i know we have the cutter for the tape
now
i like how they use tape they do the
same in resident evil
7 i think yeah there it is look at that
i mean i guess it makes sense i just
feel like you could easily just
peel that [__] off but that's just my
opinion
it's his first day guys dude
uh combined what does that mean can i
combine
am i missing something essential here
hello
hello all right i ain't scared
i ain't scared of no one nothing scares
me
hi drunt get it
all right they want me to look at this
guy but there's going to be a guy here i
know video games
oh oh oh
oh dude that looks super gross ew
stop you [__] fetisher dude like why
are you looking at that oh he's gonna
turn her up now i don't like this you
stay dead
stay dead okay don't make me kill you
and you too
how do you even get up there how does
that happen
oh god that fun oh god [__] you
this game man scarier than i thought
i mean i'm not scared hello a swedish
pewdiepie here
don't shoot alright we'll go through
here
for no reason we can board up the window
yeah [__] it why not bam
i don't know if i'm supposed to do that
but i'm going with my gut
which i hope to keep intact thank you
very much unlike some people in this
chip hey don't break the window it's
ah oh yeah you
oh your face oh god stop
that's kind of cute
oh god oh god hey i stopped i'm sorry
i'm sorry
you looked funny
dude like some people live forever i
don't trust like
when they try and divert your attention
like that
it's like even though i have a lot of
experience with horror games
i can't maybe it's because i'm an idiot
but like it still tricks me
weapon locker keypad car
like i i talked to a lot of horror game
developers and they all
kind of say the same thing that horror
games don't scare them because
they know the ins and outs of like how
it works
september 25th we're turning the station
into a temporary shelter due to the
massive sun outbreak
uh
all police personnel have been
instructed to make the safety of the
citizens of the top priority as we try
to accommodate as many of them as
possible
seven september 25th damned them one of
the refugees
attacked us in the middle of the night
resulting in the death of one officer
and injuring three others
the person in question was quickly
restrained we believe this was simply a
case of someone snapping under intense
stress
so there's a bunch of refugees that were
infected what are you trying to tell me
japan a mob attacked the station today
resulting in a number of casualties a
few survivors were able to make it
safely behind the enemy's shutters
but surrounded sbr it will be hard for
us to escape this place we're not sure
how we can fix
any of our calm equipment we so we can
uh so we remain caught up from the
outside world
september 27th there was another clash
on the west side of the station around 1
pm 12 people died
and there's only a handful of survivors
left everything is falling
into this array here david ford hero
my name is david ford it's not going
very well here's a map
oh look okay so our map got bigger oh my
god
i have not connected my elgato lights
yet so they turn themselves
off automatically i just need to set it
up
i'm too lazy so we'll get that happening
every once in a while and we can pretend
that it's something related to the video
game
i clicked there without thinking jesus
christ okay look at this epic
epic gamer aim oh dude he's fat
oh god
i wish i could stomp them uh
what is it different no same
no one really does uh horror games as
good as japanese though
they really know how to make it so much
more
actually intriguing than the westerns
even though there are there are good
questions oh god
dude you were supposed to be dead
is he dead you know he kind of still
moves he's kind of disturbing
dude are you dead bro are you dead bro
you dead bro he's dead what a loser
i don't trust anyone
oh that looks really creepy and graphics
look a bit off
okay we need a code
we can get a bag oh this is locker room
i love the design of this
really cool oh we can get some cancer
stuff
right we probably just have to go [__]
how much time do i have left
excuse me eight minutes no no i was
loving this come on
oh geez all right
all right just come in can i shoot
through here
yeah i can't oh he lost his oh [__] he
keeps
wiggling
he's dead
[Applause]
you tricked me not the epist
oh god i'm panicking
what a move slick daddy boy
so wait how do i use the knife i forgot
already it was like r1
oh [__] sorry i was trying to hit the
knife button
oh there we can board it up
let's put it up before he gets in
sorry shall we oopsie
oh yeah these heal you these [__]
herbs
how's my help though how do i know what
my health is
i think i get hit once at least
hello barb whale
that does not sound good dude dude like
you don't want to do this
trust me oh dude that's gotta lighten up
feel good
oh and he's gone ah
dude like why don't you do that i'm
sorry
i'm sorry bro it's okay
hey look we made it
uh i need a green herb that will fix
that
well i'm hitting a lot of dead ends
ill ew you're ugly and disgusting okay
we're fine
oh of course
probably says there's a note somewhere
this is goddamn
japanese games you actually have to use
your brain instead hey look
we can get a shotgun give me the shotgun
oh dude i thought we had a deal why did
i shoot him in the ass now he's just
gonna be pissed
oh god he walks so weird all right
ah dude i'm sorry about that shot that
was uncalled for
do you think zombies feel pain
oh wait sorry i have something in my
inventory uh
key card we have the key card are you
kidding me
uh i don't really have time to run back
now five minutes
[__] okay let's do it really quick yeah
see i want the weapon
there it is that's my boy or girl
not trying discrimination
w850 000 one of the most powerful
weapons in the market
w reload
i wish okay all right
now it's gamer time boys
and girls
and everyone else we're all gamers here
we all understand each other we if the
world would love each other
the world would be a better place
i wish zombies would apply that oh you
look at that you see a silhouette what
is that for
where's that shadow coming from what is
that oh it's from here okay
key very epic
oh i could could i just grab the key no
okay there's more here
oh god
dude we are like the same human leon we
have like the same thoughts
things in japanese
combine it i don't have any inventory
okay let's do this i'm
fine restore it to full health
we'll restore small amount okay use
combine
um [__] all right i'll get it later if i
have to
i can't grab that either
shawty
oh so now i have more inventory perfect
could not have come in better timing
okay i'm not gonna read these just from
the fact that
the gameplay is limited
instead i'm gonna waste time running
around for gunpowder
so there must be something i can do with
this combine
well ain't got time
c4
do we shoot that
nope good wasted ammo
gotta say i'm genuinely enjoying this
game very cool
thank you felix very cool right
no no no you idiot oh my god he's
actually going down
dude i'm getting epic at this
sometimes they take that final shot oh
god all right
oh god she looks so creepy
yeah that was awesome
okay i won't do that now because i don't
know if i need to even be here you're
not dead yet
oh god
[Laughter]
oh the shotgun is amazing
oh this library is so pretty you're not
dead yet
no you're dead
oh there's another puzzle here
okay
so this is the unicorn okay so this is
the other one
oh god no no no
damn damn time's up
experience the rest of the story in the
full game
what the frick resident evil i was just
about to enjoy myself
that was actually really fun uh if you
enjoyed as well and want me to play the
full game when it comes out
let me know smash like subscribe all
that good stuff
alright uh that's it for me for now i'll
see you guys tomorrow